find the reciprocal of two and
four-fifths so if we want to invert this
fraction we have to write it as a pure
fraction first or as an improper
fraction right now it's just a mixed
number so let's just write it as an
improper fraction so two
and 4
over 5
if we write it as an improper fraction
still going to be over 5 but the
numerator is now going to be
5 times 2 plus 4 and that's because 2 is
ten fifths or two times five fifths so
let's write it like that so it's going
to be two times five
two times five
plus four
two times five plus four two times five
is ten
ten fifths is the same thing as two and
then the four-fifths is this four-fifths
right there so this is going to be equal
to two times five is ten plus four is
fourteen
over 5. so these are equivalent
fractions this is written as a mixed
number this is written as an improper
fraction it's improper because the
numerator is bigger than the denominator
now we want to find the reciprocal when
you find the reciprocal you just switch
the numerator and the denominator you
just flip the fraction so if you want to
take the reciprocal let me do this in a
new color
if we want to
take the reciprocal
reciprocal
of this we just swap the 5 and the 14.
so this is going to be instead of 14
over 5 is going to be 5
over 14. and we're done